just a faster the bastard of Robert of
the house Baratheon first of his name
king of the Andals in the first man
there is power in a king's blood
hey everybody you've been asking for a
Gendry video so we need to talk about
where he's been this whole time what
he's been doing and why he's so
important for the story going forward so
just careful for spoilers for everything
that's happened on the show so far
there's a new round of the HBO now
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so Gendry rolling in that boat the
last place that he was seen was rowing
into the Narrow Sea off to parts unknown
Davos just told him to go hide out to
stay as quiet as he could there are a
number of different places that he could
have gone in a number of reasons why
he's significant thematically to Game of
Thrones and why he should come back as
well as political practical reasons why
he's important to the story and there's
a lot of speculation that he's actually
part of Jon Snow's party really late in
the game but that doesn't answer any
questions about what they're going to be
doing with him early in the story what
he's been doing this whole time in what
his future on the show is because now
that we're in season 7 people are
dropping like flies so let's start with
where he's been he's growing from
Dragonstone here in the books he's
actually at the end of the crossroads he
stays with the Brotherhood he doesn't go
anywhere but that's because they had a
drink storm he's the one that gets taken
to Dragonstone by Melisandre he's the
one that gets the leeches so it's always
possible the Gendry could have just gone
back to the end of the crossroads they
kind of gave that moment to hot pie
where he later runs into Podrick and
Brienne who are looking for Santa he was
looking for Arya so it'll be funny to
see all those missed connections play
out on-screen when everybody finally
gets their reunion and I will address
potential Gendry Arya reunion because I
think that that's something that's
totally possible but there are a lot of
other really big Arya reunions that
they've already been teasing so those
are slightly bigger than Gendry stuff
and he seems like he's going to be a
relatively minor part of the story but
if you see Gendry rowing south here he
was rowing in a south direction he'd
actually have to rode north up into the
bay of crabs all the way around the
crown lands to get back to the end of
the crossroads and really book Gendry
was just still with the Brotherhood so I
think that's another strike against him
being in that area just because if he
were still with the Brotherhood we would
have seen him during season six when
Thoreau's and Barrack found the how did
they were
hanging up all those people in when they
headed north we'd see him in all the
preview images and I think they want to
make him more of a surprise so it seems
like he did the Dumber thing and just
rode back to King's Landing back to the
Lions Den and he's been there ever since
the end of season 3 meaning that he's
been there through all of Circe's
wildfire her blowing up the faith
militant her walk of shame he actually
might have seen that but he probably
tried to lay low like when they're in
the cells during season 3 and they're
bonding over their crappy upbringing
like oh we came from nothing he's
talking about flea bottom
Gendry probably just went back to the
really crappy parts of King's Landing
maybe he's been hiding out there maybe
he went back to being a Smith he could
go relatively unnoticed and even though
Cersei and Qyburn have their little
birds they believe that all of Roberts
bastards have been killed so I don't
think that Cersei would actively be
looking for Gendry after season 3 season
fours over because Joffrey way back
during the first season Joffrey is the
one that sent the troops around killing
all of Roberts known bastards so that's
why they sent Gendry way in the first
place so you could call it convenient
you could call it a plot hole whatever
you want but it sounds like Gendry would
be able to lay low in King's Landing
without people finding out about him
because there aren't that many people
that knew who he was to begin with so
based on the timeline unless he
travelled somewhere else after coming
back to King's Landing he would have
been there since the beginning of season
4 but then there's the political
importance of Gendry so in the show
right now you have Cersei on the throne
you have you're on that wants to take
the throne you have Jon Snow King in the
north
doesn't want to take the throne but the
other people the north would probably
want him to take it too and then you
have the Targaryen restoration so for
the most part you have team Cersei and
you have team Daenerys and while it
sounds like Cersei is going to be
pressured to entertain suitors Gendry
even though he could be a contender for
the throne is more likely another
possible suitor for Daenerys whether or
not she wants to entertain husband's
because yes you could put a queen on the
throne Cersei is on the throne now there
is no king but it just depends on what
the realm will tolerate would they
tolerate the absence of a legitimate
heir that would be the primary reason
for making them marry
someone making Daenerys Mary Gendry or
Jon Snow or another suitor right now the
house of Baratheon is effectively dead
people have been asking me about storms
and since last season what's going to
happen to it
jamie has been promising bran bigger and
bigger castles for all the work that
he's been doing for them storms and
would be that bigger castle that they
could give to them and even if you're on
were to come and help Cersei she could
also grant storms end to him as well in
addition to the Iron Islands just like
Harrenhal has been passed around a
number of times throughout the run of
the show they could also do the same
thing with storm's end but even if
Gendry doesn't become another suitor for
Daenerys she takes the Iron Throne she
could legitimize him give him the
Baratheon name ingrain him all of his
family's ancestral lands that completely
depends on him wanting to take that name
because back during season five Stannis
offered to legitimize Jon Snow he
declined
Gendry could do the same thing as well
but I do think that we'll see a
resurrection of house Baratheon through
Gendry I don't think that he's going to
die during season seven I think there
are too many things that they can use
him for that are important to season
eight primarily his ability is a Smith
and his blood the more magical reasons
so now we get into war for the dawn
Gendry is effectively a backup Jon Snow
he has Kings blood in him there's no
real sliding scale of how pure your
blood has to be and how powerful it can
be Jon Snow the child of Ice and Fire
would arguably have more powerful blood
just because the line of Targaryen Kings
goes back much further than the line of
Baratheon Kings but according to
Melisandre King's blood is King's blood
so Gendry is important for fighting
White Walkers but he's also a very good
Smith and they have an obsidian factory
at Dragonstone so it's possible that be
a Sam Wells character at the Citadel
they could also learn how to forge
Valyrian steel or at least learn some of
the secrets and Gendry could start to
learn how to do that so just to be clear
Valyrian steel and obsidian are equally
as good at fighting White Walkers in the
night King but obsidian doesn't need to
be Smith's it's just something that you
can actually carve and chip and shape
into weapons you don't actually need to
combine it with other metals
in order to make it effective like Mira
takes down a white Walker underneath the
tree here with an obsidian tip spear it
just literally lashed to the tip of a
spear and it works just fine
so if Gary is going to be fighting with
a weapon it would probably be a giant
war hammer
just like his father Robert Baratheon
because they like to do things like that
on the TV show and it's visual rhyming
for Robert's rebellion and yes I do
think we'll see some flashbacks so it's
always possible we could see Robert
fighting with his war hammer before we
see Kendra fighting with his war hammer
but our your reunion so I know
everybody's wondering we'll Gendry and
aria meet up because aria is headed for
Winterfell she'll get there eventually
and it sounds like most of her storyline
will be adjacent to Sansa what's going
on with Littlefinger the plot in the
north but based on his current location
Gendry wouldn't run into her unless he
were to make it back from their trip
north of the wall if he's part of that
party with Jon Snow so if there is a
Gendry reunion it would be most likely
that it would happen at the very end of
the season so let me know in the
comments what do you think they're going
to do with Gendry this season what do
you think he's been doing this whole
time in which episode if he shows up do
you think that he will finally see Arya
again and there's just too many
important things they could use him for
on this show and I know a lot of people
are like maybe he's going to be the
AEGON of the show the other contender
for the throne I think that's more
likely Jon Snow's character and they've
completely cut that plot out like no one
will legit challenge to nearest for the
right to the throne like Jon Snow isn't
going to write up on Dragonstone and say
I deserve the Iron Throne he's just
going to try and deal with the White
Walkers and then we can just speculate
on the people around Jon Snow and how
they'll react to that because they're
mostly concerned with an alliance in
dealing with what's happening in the
north really the Iron Throne seems like
it's becoming less and less important
that Davos live it won't matter whose
skeleton sits on the Iron Throne they're
literally telling you in the trailer
that by the end of this season nobody's
going to care about that because of what
the night King is doing so if you guys
didn't know
konna Thrones has been this past weekend
it's been really cool I didn't have the
chance to go this year
although sue from Watchers on the wall
was really nice and asked me to sit on a
couple panels hopefully in future years
I'll actually be able to do that so
sorry to everybody who I missed a Khan
of Thrones
hopefully you guys had a good time
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Shamy Ames please private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
can get your contact details you can
click here to rewatch the trailer and
you can click here for my Ozora high
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight